- I think the stat is 78%
of athletes go bankrupt
within two years, NFL players
go bankrupt within two years
after they retire.
And you think to yourself,
like you made all this money,
how did you not be smarter with it?
Well, they never taught us in school,
how to manage our finances
and how to save money
and how to invest money.
They don't teach you these
things when all you care
about is sports.
So I didn't make that much
money playing arena football.
I made $250 a week and we had food stamps.
So I was living in Huntsville, Alabama,
and eating Chick-fil-A and
whatever else I could eat from
the food stamps.
And so there was no money that I saved.
My sister brought me in and
let me crash at her house,
it was supposed to be for about a month.
A month turned into a year and a half
and she gave me an incredible gift.
She said, "Okay, you
gotta start paying rent,"
after a year and a half.
(dynamic music)
- This is the Rubin report,
and I'm still Dave Rubin.
Friendly reminder guys to
subscribe to our YouTube channel
and click that pesky notification bell
so that you might just see our new videos
when they come out.
And joining me today is a New York Times
bestselling author, a business coach,
and the host of the School
of Greatness Podcast,
Lewis Howes, welcome to the Rubin report.
- My man, thanks for having me.
- I'm glad to have you here.
We got to get some simple
stuff out of the way
before we do anything.
First off, I love that freaking jacket.
- I know.
- I almost bought
that jacket--
- It's amazing.
- I'm jealous about the jacket.
That's like Han Solo modern, I love it.
- It's clean, right?
- It's clean,
I want that jacket.
- Just a little touch
of like, the accents are super clean.
- You put anything in there?
- I don't, no.
I should.
I've only worn this a few times,
so I should probably wear it more.
I put this on for you.
I knew you were gonna wear a jacket
and I normally just wear a
black shirt, but I was like,
let me wear something a little bit nicer.
We're an actual professional studio here.
I had to dress up.
- Well, you got a pretty
professional operation too.
I did your podcast in the
midst of the lockdown.
It's the only live in-person interview
that I did in the whole thing.
We actually--
- We shook hands.
- Well, we fist bumped
and then we realized,
let's just do it.
- Yeah, exactly.
- And we actually shook hands.
- And then we found out right afterwards
that you hit the New York
Times bestseller list
for your big book, so.
- It was in your studio that I found out.
- Magic happens with us.
- Two New York Times bestselling authors.
There we go, there we go.
All right, there's a ton I
want to talk to you about,
and I'm glad we're doing
this because you know,
I do a lot of politics in here.
I do a lot of culture wars and all that,
but I think underneath all
of that is a human thing
that I think you are really
excelling at at the moment.
So before we get into that, though,
for the people that have
no idea who you are,
who is Lewis Howes?
How the hell did he get that fancy jacket,
and what's he doing here?
- I'm a human being on a quest
to discover more of myself,
how I can become better and
how I can make a big impact
on the people around me.
And I've always cared
about human performance.
I've always just wanted to excel
at the things I care about.
I think from an early age,
I did it to try to prove people wrong
because I felt unseen, unheard, un-liked,
unloved by everyone around me.
And even though that wasn't the truth,
that's just how I felt.
My parents were there for me.
My older siblings were there,
but I just didn't feel like
I fit in in a lot of ways.
And especially in school,
I was very dyslexic.
If I even try to read my own book
I'd probably struggle reading my own words
that I wrote down, just
because I've always
struggled with that.
And I was in special needs classes
from as long as I can remember.
During recess and lunch breaks in school,
I would be with tutors.
So I didn't get to do a lot of the things
that normal kids would do.
And I just felt always insecure
and insignificant in my abilities.
And that kind of stayed with me.
And I use sports as my afterschool
kind of program to say,
what can I do if school is
something I struggle in,
where in high school, they would,
I don't know if they did
this in your high school,
but they would actually
rank us in our class
on our report cards.
So I was always in the bottom four
of the student class.
- Like, purely on grade?
- They would like say like if
there're a hundred students,
I was like always 96 out of a hundred
or 100 out of a hundred based on your GPA.
So I would always see that number
and dread it every quarter,
we would get our report card,
and I'd always see I'm on the bottom four.
I never broke out of the
bottom four in school.
So it was just a very
challenging time for me to,
to think about it.
And that's what we judged
ourselves on it in school growing
up was like, who can read faster?
Who's smarter, who got
A's and who got D's?
And so I use sports as my
outlet to say, I'm, you know,
I'm gonna become bigger, faster,
and stronger than everyone else around me.
I'm gonna show them that I'm
worthy of love and worthy
of their attention, I'm
worthy of being picked first,
not being last.
And I just put my energy into
that and made my dreams around
that because I started to
get really good at sports.
And that became kind of my
mission until I got injured,
playing football.
- Then sports ends.
And then that--
- Then my dream,
my identity, you know, kind of falls apart
because I got injured
playing arena football.
And I had, I mean, this is
in 2008 when the economy,
it was the end of 2007,
the economy is crashing.
I remember I didn't have
a college degree yet,
because I left early to go play football,
try to make the NFL.
Wasn't good enough to make it.
And I had no money.
I had college debt that
I was trying to pay off.
I didn't have a job.
And I remember trying to go on LinkedIn
to find jobs in 2007, 2008.
And no one was hiring people
without a college degree in 2008,
let alone with master's degrees.
They were having a hard
time getting a job.
So I just remember saying to
myself, what am I gonna do?
I'm sleeping on my sister's
couch at this time for a year
and a half, trying to
figure out one, who am I?
I lost my dream.
I lost the ability to
work out at this moment.
Everything I put my
identity around to is gone.
I have no clue what to do next.
And this might be a first world problem.
But for me, my identity was gone
and I didn't know who I was in the world
or why I was even supposed
to be here anymore.
- How dark was that time?
Because you see, you hear this
with athletes all the time,
major pro guys that you
know, they blow out the knee
and it's over, and then, you know,
you find out that they're
living on the streets
five years later, all sorts--
- I think the stat is 78%
of athletes go bankrupt
within two years, NFL players go bankrupt
within two years after they retire.
And you think to yourself,
like you made all this money,
how did you not be smarter with it?
Well, they never taught us in school,
how to manage our finances
and how to save money and
how to even invest money.
They don't teach you these
things when all you care
about is sports.
So I didn't make that much
money playing arena football.
I made $250 a week and we had food stamps.
So I was living in Huntsville, Alabama,
and eating Chick-fil-A and whatever else
I could eat from the food stamps.
And so there was no money that I saved.
My sister brought me in and
let me crash at her house.
It was supposed to be for about a month.
A month turned into a year and a half.
And she gave me an incredible gift.
She said, "Okay, you
gotta start paying rent,"
after a year and a half.
So that push finally got me
to say, "Okay, I need to learn
"if I'm not gonna go get a job somewhere."
I started truck driving for $250 a week.
I was driving Napa car auto
parts for six hours a day.
- 250 was your sweet spot.
- 250 was my sweet spot.
I couldn't break that limit.
So I was like, "How do I get past this?"
And at the same time,
I was also reaching out
to people on LinkedIn,
finding, trying to find mentors.
I was just trying to
interview people personally
and ask them questions about
how do I achieve anything after sports.
I just had no clue how to do it.
And she gave me a great gift.
She said, "You've got to start helping
"and contributing to the rent."
And I didn't know what I was gonna do.
I really just like, "I don't
know what I'm gonna do,"
but I applied for a job on LinkedIn.
I found a sports marketing job
'cause I eventually graduated
and applied for a sports marketing job.
And I got an interview.
My first ever interview that
I got when applying for a job.
And for whatever reason,
I had my one nice sport
jacket from like college.
I dressed up and I'm leaving
the house, my sister's house.
I open the door to walk out to the street
and I can't take a step out of the house.
For whatever reason,
I'm unable to actually
leave the house and
shut the door behind me.
'Cause for whatever,
I was either so egotistical at the moment
or just believed in myself
so much that I was like,
"If I go to this interview,
"I'm gonna get the interview
"and I'm gonna get the job,
"and they're gonna hire me
"'cause I'm gonna be so convincing
"that they're gonna need me.
"And then I'm gonna stay
here for two, three years
"and I'm not gonna enjoy what I'm doing.
"And then I'm gonna
feel trapped and stuck."
And I just didn't want
to go down that route.
So that gave me the courage to say,
"Okay, I need to go figure
out how to make money
"on my own because I've
never made a dime."
I wasn't this entrepreneurial
kid doing lemonade stands
and selling baseball cards
and making shoe accessories
or whatever in school,
I was just trying to play sports.
And so I had no entrepreneurial
bone in my body,
but the necessity to just
survive and be able to contribute
to rent and pay for my own food
as a 24 year old at the time,
25 year old became apparent.
And that was the push that I needed.
And so I left my sister's house,
moved to my brother's place
and started paying him, guess how much?
- 250.
- 250 a month, right!
(laughing)
And stayed there for about six months.
And for whatever reason, that investment,
even though it was $250
was a way for me to think,
"Okay, how do I make 500 a month
so I can get a month ahead?
"How do I make a thousand a month?"
It just started getting
me thinking differently
because I was forced to,
and that was 2009 and here we are now.
- And then it's been an
interesting 11 years.
- It's been an interesting journey.
- So you mentioned some
of the growing up stuff
and self esteem.
So I know it's not the most
fun thing to talk about
in the world, but you were molested
when you were five years old.
- Yeah.
- Can you just break it down a little bit?
'Cause I think it does
sort of frame a lot--
- Yeah, it frames a lot.
- The way you look
at the world, obviously.
- One in six men have been sexually abused
in some way in America,
which I had no clue about these
statistics until I started
to open up about my sexual abuse
and started to research it.
I just thought I was the only
boy that had ever been abused
and therefore I was
worthless, I was helpless.
And if people actually knew this about me,
they would never love me.
They would never accept me.
People would laugh at
me and make fun of me.
That was the fear inside.
And I think we talked about
this a little bit where,
you know, I can't imagine
what it's like being gay,
coming out, the fear that you might have
if there's a lot of pressure against you,
but I think we can, you know,
understand each other in that,
in that sense of like something
you're afraid to share
people where you don't
think you'd be accepted.
That's where I felt.
And I felt like, you know, I was,
when I was five, I was sexually abused,
and when I was eight, my
brother went to prison
for four and a half years.
So I would go visit a prison
visiting room every weekend.
And I remember walking in the first time
and just being so intimidated and scared.
And we were the only white family there.
There was a lot of black and Mexican,
Latino families in the visiting
room seeing the inmates.
And I remember thinking to
myself after many months
I would get to talk to some
of these inmates and just,
I was a curious eight year old,
I would just go say hi to people.
And I was like, "These
inmates are really nice.
"You know, they're very kind,
"they're sitting here praying,
they're with their families.
"They're having good conversations."
Like it made me think
differently about inmates.
Now, some of them had
done really bad things,
were murderers and drug
dealers and things like that.
But it got me thinking about
different perspectives of life.
However, I wasn't allowed to have friends
during those four years
because the neighborhood kids
weren't allowed to hang out with me.
So I was in a white neighborhood
and having my brother go to prison,
the parents wouldn't allow
their kids to hang out with me.
- I wasn't sure what you meant there.
- So, so I was sexually abused
and then I just felt
like I was never enough.
I was kind of picked on
in school for my dyslexia
and learning abilities.
I was, my brother was in prison
for four and a half years.
So just the neighborhood talk,
don't hang out with Lewis.
He's a bad apple also.
So it's just like, it
just, I was just like,
"Why is this all happening?"
And I think that made me question
a lot of why I was even alive
and I would get in
trouble in school and say,
you know, "I wish I were dead."
I would say this all the
time to the principal.
"I wish I were dead,
I wish I wasn't here."
And so I think I was just
always on the journey
of trying to figure out like,
what's the purpose of my life.
What's the meaning of everyone's life?
How do we find a place
where we can love ourselves,
accept ourselves for who we are,
what we've been through
and how can we discover
what our gifts, our purposes, our dreams
and figure out a way
to make them come true.
That's been kind of my journey.
- So a lot of that works
at the, at the adult level,
but for the five-year-old
going through this,
how long did it last and how did you,
how did you come out about?
- I think it lasts, it lasts 25 years
of having the story of the
sexual abuse in my mind
every single day, like replaying the movie
of it happening every single day.
But also kind of deflecting
it a lot too and just saying,
"Okay, it wasn't that big of a deal.
"Like it is what it is, it happened.
"I'm gonna move on.
"Like, don't be such a wuss,
"like whatever, it's not a big deal."
And when I was 30, I was at the height
of a lot of things in my career.
I had built and sold a
business for seven figures.
I had started getting accomplishments
and awards as a business entrepreneur.
You know, I'd played
professional football.
I was on the USA national handball team
trying to make the Olympics,
running a business,
starting this podcast,
like things were happening
for my career and on an
accomplishment level.
But the more success I achieved,
the more unfulfilled I felt inside.
And I didn't understand why.
I just thought, "Okay,
I'm not doing enough.
"I need to go achieve more."
And I was also, I had also
moved to LA from New York city
for a girl and in a relationship I was in,
and then we didn't work
out really quickly.
The day I moved here,
she broke up with me,
and just kind of like--
- The day you got here?
- The day I landed.
- Wow.
- She kind of like sabotaged it,
she was scared and we got back together
and tried to make it work,
but it was like an emotional
roller coaster and this
whole kind of next six months
was kind of another re identity,
trying to figure out who am I?
What am I doing here?
What's happening in this relationship?
I just sold this business.
And I just started getting
angry all the time.
I didn't know why I was so angry,
but this was kind of a common theme
throughout my life of being triggered
when I felt taken advantage
of or abused in any situation,
whether it be a personal relationship,
a business partnership or
friendship, a family member.
If I felt like someone was abusing me,
it would trigger me and
didn't understand why.
And I remember my friend,
Matt, who's here right now.
We started playing
basketball a lot together
on the pickup courts on the
mean streets of Beverly Hills.
- I'm sure I've played on those--
- Super mean streets of
West Hollywood actually.
You probably know I'm talking about.
In San Vicente park.
- Oh yeah.
- And we'd play three, four times a week.
And for whatever reason, I
would get really aggressive
at the smallest amount
of trash talk, right?
Some 20 year old punk would be like,
"Oh, this and this about
your mom" or whatever.
And I would be so aggressive
back towards them.
I would scream at them, I
would get in their face.
I would shove people.
I would try to impose my
intimidation will against everyone
on the court because I felt
under attack constantly.
I didn't know how to have like manage it.
And one day I got in a pretty
bad fight on the basketball
court where I actually
got into a fist fight,
you know, with another guy.
And remember at the end of it,
this is right across
from a police station.
- Oh, literally.
- You know what
I'm talking about?
Literally across the street.
- On the other side
of the street, yeah.
- And I remember thinking to myself--
- We probably played
together at some point,
because I used to play there.
- I might have punched you
in the face for all I know.
No, I'm just kid--
- That is very possible!
I don't trash talk that much.
- No yeah, sure.
- I let the place
speak for itself.
(laughing)
- You're just dropping threes all day.
I remember Matt was like, you know,
get out of here because people
are making threats about
like, I'm gonna go to my car and get my,
people were saying crazy stuff
about what they were gonna
do to me after this.
And I remember being like
looking at the police station
being like, I could lose
everything for something stupid,
getting into a fight as a 30 year old man.
Like, what am I doing?
It's a basketball game.
We're trying to have fun here.
And I remember running back to my home
and looking in the
mirror and just shaking.
I was just shaking.
I was like wiping off like
the blood on my knuckles.
I was just like looking myself
in the eye for the first time
in a long time, and I
couldn't recognize myself.
And I was just like, who are you?
Who are you, and what are you doing,
and what is wrong with you?
And just looking myself in
the eyes and asking me those,
myself, those questions was
a, was a big eyeopener for me.
'Cause I don't think we do this enough.
I don't think we ask ourselves,
who are we, what am I doing?
What is my mission?
Am I doing everything I can do?
- Do you think that's the
most fundamental question?
I mean, for all the
people you've interviewed
and talked to you and
coached and all that,
that that right there, is
it more than anything else?
- I think the great
individuals in the world
are clear on their vision and they,
they know exactly what they
want and why they want it.
I didn't know what I
wanted and why I wanted it.
I knew I wanted to prove people wrong.
I wanted to look good.
I wanted to be right.
I wanted to make money.
I wanted to be successful,
but it wasn't for a greater purpose.
It was for me to look good
and to prove the person
who sexually abused me wrong,
to prove the kids that laughed
at me when I was reading
aloud in class wrong, to
prove the kids that picked
me last in a sport wrong.
It was always to prove people wrong,
not to lift others up.
And it's really challenging
to constantly want to tear
someone else down and other people down.
It's exhausting, constantly doing this.
You're seeing this in the
political space right now
where people are just
attacking each other.
I'm like, that's gotta be
exhausting at the end of the night
to just like go to sleep
when you're that much rage
and anger towards something else.
And I'm all for fighting
for what you believe in,
and fighting for a great cause
and fighting for equality
and all these things,
but to aggressively want
to prove others wrong,
in my opinion is a painful act.
And I'd rather just focus on a
vision and try to lift others
up with you in that vision.
So I think that's what a lot of people
have that I've interviewed is,
the great ones, find a clear vision.
They accept themselves fully.
They know they're not perfect
'cause none of us are.
They have come to
acceptance with their past,
the wrongs they've done,
the things that they're not proud of,
but they've accepted it,
and they've moved towards
something greater than
just seeking success.
'Cause success is all about us.
Greatness is about others.
Success is about what I can
do for myself to look good.
Greatness is what I can do for
other people to lift them up.
And I think that's when
you transition from just
accomplishing something
as a great athlete,
towards transitioning
into something greater
or accomplishing as a
great business leader
towards how can I truly
serve my employees,
serve my clients and customers,
and then serve the world around me.
And I think that's the difference
between success and greatness.
- That's a pretty solid
Segway for about 30 reasons
to get to a little bit of
your chat with Kobe Bryant,
because I think it encapsulates
so much of what you're talking about.
So I watched it again this morning
and we talked about it
when I was on your show.
And I hadn't seen the
interview of you and Kobe.
And what I said to you in that interview
was that this was just a few
weeks after, after he died,
is that it felt like it was
like a rip in the universe
because it's hard to fathom,
putting aside the tragedy
of all the other people and
his daughter, of course,
but those aren't public
people that we know,
but of course it's as, as
equal a tragedy obviously.
But there was something
about Kobe that it was like,
I told you, I was watching sports,
you know, the spectrum Lakers
channel the day before.
And I saw him and he was
just being interviewed
and he's in a suit and he's got the beard
and he looks really sharp.
And I was like, man, that guy's
just living his best life.
That was literally the day before.
- Wow.
- And it feels like a rip in the universe
when someone who's doing all of the things
that you just described,
who has reached the
pinnacle of their sport,
but then flourished after
and started this basketball
Academy and a gajillion other things,
then disappears from the earth.
So can you just talk a little
bit about what it was like
to sit down with Kobe
and what it taught you
and did he have all of those pieces?
'Cause, literally just everything
that you just laid out right there,
that's what he was talking
about in the interview.
And you could see it was real,
there was no BS behind it--
- Yeah.
- You really could.
- It was a powerful experience.
The whole, the whole
setup of it was powerful.
We booked the interview the day before.
So I didn't really have much time to prep,
which was probably a good thing for me.
'Cause I didn't have like
two weeks to think about it.
I've got Kobe.
It was like literally
booked it at six p.m.
I think the night before.
And then I was there at
six a.m. the next morning
in his office in the OC.
And I remember the most
powerful thing he taught
me was not what he said, but his example.
And what I mean by that is
when we got to his office,
I think it was probably around 6:15, 6:30,
the interview was at eight
o'clock and I knew I was,
the publicist was like,
"You got 20 minutes."
I think she originally said,
"You've got 15 minutes,"
but I was like, "Please give me 20."
Right, when I asked two questions.
Yeah, we get there.
And the assistant opens the door for us,
and there's a big office
space in the Orange County.
And she says, "Here's
where we normally film."
But in my mind I was like,
"Yeah, it doesn't really look that good.
"Can I look around the office
"and see if there's another spot
"we can set up our cameras?"
So we walked through the office
and we go down kind of this
long hall with conference rooms
on each side of the
hallway with glass windows,
you can see inside the conference rooms.
And then it walks down into
another big open space of more
office chairs and things like that.
We walked down, I see the other room.
I'm like, "I don't really
like anything here.
"Let's go back to the original space."
So we walked back
through the glass hallway
and the last window on the left, I see it.
The lights are off in
the back of the room,
probably 20, 30 feet back.
I see a shadow of a man
like this looking up.
Just looking up at the ceiling.
And no computer screen was on,
there was no phone in his hand.
And I look real quick
double-take and I see it's Kobe
sitting there like this, just looking up.
This is 6:15 in the morning.
And I'm thinking," Our
interview's not till eight."
And I'm thinking to myself,
I asked the assistant,
I go, "Is that Kobe?"
She goes, "Yeah."
And I go, "What's he doing here so early?
"Like this is his company.
"This is his space, why is he here?"
She goes, "He's been
here for almost an hour."
And he was at the gym with his daughter.
The one who passed away, at
four a.m. working out with her.
And he comes here, he's
always the first one here.
And he's always the most prepared.
And I'll go, just that
moment alone of seeing Kobe
as a shadow, looking up.
And I can only imagine he
was visualizing his dream.
He was going over, you know,
his game film for the day,
he was planning what he
was gonna be talking about.
There was an interview with me afterwards,
with Lil Wayne who was there.
So they were sitting up in another part.
It was kind of surreal just morning.
- Yeah.
- Lil Wayne and all
his body guards and this
whole crew was there.
I'm there with one person
setting up our three cameras
and we're like, "Hey," you know?
And I was just like, "This is surreal."
And about an hour, about 15
minutes before our interview,
so for another hour, hour and half,
the lights are off in this room.
And now people starting
to come in around 8:30
in the office, and so there's some,
there's some activity happening.
And I'm sitting there in the
chair, just kind of waiting,
just trying to like be ready.
I don't know if he's gonna come out early.
Is it coming out on time?
I don't know what's happening.
He ends up coming out
probably two minutes before
eight o'clock start time.
And the publicist gave me a
bunch of papers of everything
not to ask him.
A list of things you cannot talk about
from his past, or parents
to all these things.
Like don't mention this,
don't mention this.
I mean a list, I've never had this before.
And so I know to myself, I've
got two minutes to connect
with arguably the greatest of all time,
who's just won an Oscar
as well, by the way.
And two minutes to connect before
our 20 minute interview, right?
What am I gonna say?
And hopefully he doesn't,
you know when you meet people
that are really famous and
you're inspired by them,
and you meet them and you're like,
"Gosh, I'm really let down by them."
- They say, never meet your heroes.
- Right?
And this guy was the complete opposite.
He was right away came up to
me, gave me a big handshake,
and was just like, "Hey, thank
you so much for being here,
"it really means a lot to me.
"We're trying to get the
message out about our podcast.
"Like thank you for taking the time."
Looked me in the eyes.
First thing I said to him was like,
"I just want to say, thank you.
"I work with, I'm friends
with a lot of Olympians.
"And all of them say that during the last
"couple of Olympics, you
were the most giving athlete
"that you would show up
to other sporting events,
"that you would take photos
with everyone in the, you know,
"in the village and during lunches
"that you were just so kind and giving.
"So as a USA handball player,
"I want to thank you for how you show
"up during those times."
And right away, he goes,
"You play handball?"
And I go, "Yeah, I love handball."
And he goes, "I love hand ball,
"playing it in Italy growing up,
"that's all I did as a fun activity."
And I go, "Amazing, yeah,
it's such a great sport.
"I wish we had it here, the USA more."
And then I mentioned a couple of people
we had in common and he's like,
"Man, those guys are my brothers.
"Like, I love them.
"I'm glad we have some good connections."
And I said one more thing.
I said, "You know, your team
has told me what not to share
"and what not talk about.
"Is there anything else off limits
"that I shouldn't talk about?"
And he said, "Rip that up,
ask me anything you want
"and take as long as you want."
So I was only supposed to have 20 minutes.
I think we went 40 or 45,
and I tried to be respectful,
'cause the publicist kept saying like,
"Wrap it up," in the background.
And I was like, "Okay,
let me be respectful."
But even the last few
questions he answered
where he's talking about
like his whole mission
was to tell great stories
and him talking about love
and family, for me, it
was really inspiring.
Not only the words he
says, but his example.
He isn't just saying work
hard and outwork everyone,
he's actually showed me as an example.
I didn't know if he was
gonna see me seeing him
that morning, like he didn't
think I was gonna walk
past his office 'cause
I wasn't supposed to.
- Right.
- But he was there.
And just that example of, I mean,
I don't get there to my place
30 minutes before my interviews, right?
You, I guess, I mean you
come in when you're ready,
but it's like just that
example of hard work
it shows why he was so great.
And that was inspiring to me.
- Isn't it interesting that, you know,
they say the same thing
about Michael Jordan.
He outworked everybody.
He practiced the hardest,
like you'd think that every
athlete would be like,
"Oh, that's the obvious way to do it."
Or forget athletes, that
all of us in our lives
would be like, "Oh, you want
to be the best at what you do?
"You got to work the hardest.
"You've got to show up first
"and you got to leave the
last and blah, blah, blah."
And yet 99.999% of us don't do it.
Even though you look at the
guys that you admire most
and they're the ones doing it.
- It's a big sacrifice.
It's a lot of time, a
lot of energy in you.
You have to give up so much
to go all in on one thing.
So I know why it's hard to do.
I mean, it's like he was up at four a.m.
working out with his daughter
and then he was at the office
at 5:30 or whatever it was,
or six or whatever it was.
And it's like, it's a sacrifice.
We'd much rather be
comfortable and sleep more
and watch Netflix more.
I like watching Netflix.
It's not easy to be great.
It's very challenging.
The commitment, the consistency over time.
And that's one of the things Kobe said,
he's just like, "It's simple math.
"I just put in double the
hours as everyone else,
"when I was a teenager."
The first year he started
playing basketball
on a summer camp, he didn't
score one point in this whole,
like summer and this
tournament that he played in.
And then he started doing double
the hours and the next year
he was like the highest scorer.
And he was like, "It was simple math.
"I wasn't more talented.
"I simply put in more hours."
- It's a good transition to something else
that he said that I think is
interesting where he talked,
you were asking him about when he was sort
of hitting his stride.
And he talks about this
moment where Shaq is injured
for like eight games, and
he scored, I think 40,
over 40 in eight straight
games or something like that.
And then Phil Jackson
calls him into the office
when Shaq comes back
and basically is like,
"Now you got to tone it down
because now Shaq is back
"and the East plays different.
"So when we get to the finals,
"we're gonna do this differently."
And he, you know, you'd think
that he would just be like,
"No, we're winning like crazy."
"I'm better than Shaq,
we don't even need Shaq."
You know, they had their
own problems later,
but, he basically was like,
"Yeah, so I listened to the mentor."
That's what I wanted to get to,
'cause you talk a lot about mentorship.
He listened to the mentor
in this case, Phil Jackson,
who had already done this with
Jordan and he dialed it back.
And then of course they ended
up winning a championship.
- Exactly, yeah.
I think the coaches and mentors in my life
have been instrumental towards my success
through every stage, from
my parents being mentors
and coaches to my older siblings,
to teachers and coaches in school.
- Do you sense we have a
major lack of that right now?
I mean, one of the things
I keep saying on Twitter
and every time I'm on TV now is,
it seems like we don't have
a lot of adults in the room.
Not, not at an individual level,
of course there are mentors.
And we talked about, I wrote
a whole chapter about Jordan
Peterson in my book.
So it's not, it's not that
these people don't exist,
but it seems like in the public sphere,
we don't have a lot of people
right now that you can look
to and be like, "Oh,
they're modeling something.
"That is the way I want to be."
Something like that.
- I think it's hard to
have the courage to reach
out to mentors in the first
place and to identify like,
okay, The Rock.
I would love The Rock
to be my mentor, right?
Or Jordan Peterson for a young adult,
who's like, I'd love for
Jordan Peterson to be my mentor
and get in touch with him.
It may seem intimidating
to reach out to someone,
how do I get in touch with them?
Luckily, Jordan Peterson has a great book
that you could be mentored by
his talks online, his podcast.
You can go to his tours,
you can learn enough from
someone's book to hopefully
implement it and learn from their example
of what they're doing.
I really look at my model
as Oprah meets The Rock,
meets LeBron James.
And I'm trying to say,
"Okay, I want to learn
"from each one of those
and create my own model
"of success for my
mission and my purpose."
I feel like I'm a blend of all three.
I've got the athlete in LeBron James,
obviously not as half as good
an athlete as him, but that,
that Ohio brand that wanted
to give back to schools.
We, we donate a lot of money
to build schools for kids
in different countries.
So I see that model as like
"I'm a USA handball player."
I see The Rock as a former
professional football player
who's now into entertainment.
I played former football,
I was former pro, now into
kind of entertainment.
And then Oprah, who just is
a curator and facilitator
of ideas and people.
And that's what I'm doing as well.
So I try to find my mentors,
even though I've never met any of them,
I try to find them and model them.
But I have lots of coaches that I pay for,
in business, relationships,
my fitness and health
and just life.
For me, I'm such a huge
advocate of coaching.
Coaching is what Michael Jordan,
Kobe Bryant and LeBron
James all talk about,
is the key to what made them
great athletes in school.
To now as professional athletes,
you cannot win in sports,
in business and in life,
without having great
mentorship and coaches.
I just don't think you can.
You can get a far, but I
don't think you can sustain
that success over time without consistent
mentorship and guidance.
That's just my belief.
- So I had Burgess Owen
a couple of weeks ago,
who's a former NFL player
and he's now running
for Congress in Utah.
And he actually talked about
a lot of the similar things.
One of the things I asked him was,
"Do you think there's a connection
"between being a professional athlete
"and someone that can
compete at an elite level
"and then someone that can be a success
"on the other side, because
you're just using those,
"those disciplines?"
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You obviously agree with that.
- Yeah.
I think there's a lot of great athletes
who can transition and
then others who stay stuck
in their past identity.
They say, "I'm gonna
live off the past dream
"that I had, me as a great athlete.
"I'm gonna live off the money."
Where Kobe said, "Okay,
I've got all this money.
"I could retire now."
But he said, "I want to do
something great with my life
"in the next chapter.
"20 seasons playing the NBA.
"What do I want to do now?
"I want to tell great stories
"'cause that's what's
gonna change the world.
"Me not being a great athlete anymore
"is gonna change the world.
"Me creating content to tell
stories that reaches kids,
"young adults, adults, that's
what will change people's
"belief in themselves and the world."
So I think his ability to say,
"I'm gonna use these
disciplines in my business
"and figure it out."
He also had coaches and
partners in his business
that helped him and guided him.
And I think that's the key.
A lot of guys don't transition
with great coaching afterwards,
and you got to seek out
coaches or mentors constantly
because we're always facing new chapters.
You've got your business model right now,
but I know you've got big
goals and big plans ahead.
When you launched your book
and you didn't have a book
before you probably seeked
out other authors and said,
"Hey, what should I do here?
"What should, Jordan tell me how you sold
"a million copies in six months," right?
"What was the plan?
"What was the strategy?"
You're seeking mentors, whether
you're officially paying
for coaches or not, and you're
seeking it at every stage
and that's what makes you a great success.
- I described in the chapter about Jordan,
he was an accidental mentor.
We just started doing stuff together.
And then I was like, "Holy cow, this guy,
"he's changing the world
right in front of me.
"And I have the honor of being
that close to this thing?"
- Access, like every night, right?
For how long?
A year, two years?
- Like a year and a half.
And the crazy part for me
was that he never once went
backwards on one of those rules.
I never saw the guy not
live up to the things
he was talking about.
How much of this stuff do you
think is sort of hardwired
in the way people are born versus learn?
Because like on the Kobe level,
I always think about Tim Duncan
who retired the same year
Kobe did, you know, he won
five championships himself,
but he was quiet.
You didn't know anything about him.
There was no, I can't even picture
him showboating or yelling.
You can barely hear his voice.
You know, I've seen him be
interviewed a million times,
but like Kobe, you can like, you know,
hear his voice that he had.
He clearly worked hard.
He was a total pro the whole thing.
Even the way he retired,
like Kobe's retirement,
it was very public.
- It was a show, it was a performance.
- It was like Kareem, it was a show.
- I'll drop the mic, everything, yeah.
- The whole thing, like
everywhere he went, it was like,
this is Kobe's last night in Philadelphia.
Where Tim Duncan again, the same thing,
like all the success, all
that stuff, the great numbers,
but just kinda just was like
quiet about the whole thing.
How much of just like the,
all of it do you think
is just hard wiring versus--
- Environment?
- Or environment,
everything else?
- I think it's a little bit
of both because you know,
I don't think I would
have been a great athlete
had I not felt abused all the time.
So I think my environment of sexual abuse,
feeling left behind, feeling
made fun of in school.
Being picked last in sports.
In fourth grade, I was
picked last in the sports
team over girls.
And that was probably
the most like humiliating
time as a fourth grader of being like,
okay, we're in a recess
here and on the playground.
And there was a dodgeball game.
And that our class was gonna do,
it's probably 30 kids in
our class, maybe 40 kids.
Call it half man, half women, right?
And I remember there was
two captains of the game,
and both the captains were
picking one at a time, right?
You pick your top athlete.
And they picked all the guys.
And then I was the last guy, boy standing.
And then they start
picking girls one by one.
And then they pick the last girl.
This is like a girl who is, you know,
in glasses and like no
athletic bone in her body.
And they pick her and
they don't even pick me.
This is a memory, right.
They don't want to pick me.
I'm just by default, the
last person that goes
on the last team.
And I'm thinking to myself,
"I know I'm not the worst athlete here.
"This is fourth grade."
And I remember being
like these experiences
that we have shape us.
And they shaped me into
saying never again,
am I gonna feel this humiliated.
In that moment, I remember
saying never again
am I'm gonna be picked last.
I am going to the gym
every day after school.
And you're gonna stay
there till my mom calls
me home to eat dinner and just work out
and play basketball and play this sport.
That drove me, that experience.
You know, I don't know if
you have similar experiences
in your life where
maybe you felt neglected
or felt like taken advantage of,
or felt, you know,
in just because of whatever,
that made you say, "I'm gonna show you,
"I'm gonna prove you wrong."
And that drive, I think
Kobe had a lot of that drive
where he wanted to prove
people wrong as well.
And then it transitions to, okay,
this doesn't work for me anymore.
This energy works to a
certain point of achieving,
but I still feel empty.
Why?
And that's where I had that
kind of moment when I was 30.
I was like, I'm achieving a lot.
I've got money, I've got success,
but why am I feeling alone?
Why do I feel so angry still?
Like, shouldn't I feel happier?
And that's what allowed me to reflect.
And I went to a, I started
doing a lot of work on myself.
I started reaching out to
therapists, coaches, mentors,
spiritual guides, going to workshops.
And during that time of a workshop,
a lot of people were
opening up about their past.
And I remember the workshop
trainer facilitator was like,
"We are gonna be moving forward."
It was after about a few days
in this workshop, he said,
"We're gonna be moving
forward to get clear
"about what we want to
create for our future.
"But in order to get clear about
our mission and our future,
"and to be able to tackle
it with our full energy,
"we must clear the past
and forgive ourselves
"or forgive anything that's
happened in the past.
"Otherwise we're gonna be
holding onto this weight
"that's dragging us down."
I remember sitting there
thinking to myself, "Huh."
I feel like I've addressed
everything in my past.
You know, I've talked about my brother
being in prison and what that felt like,
I've talked about being picked
on and bullied in school.
I talked about, you know,
just my parents arguing
and them getting a divorce,
just like everyone else in the room.
You know, nothing's new here.
I feel like everyone's gone
through similar experiences.
So I don't know what else to talk about.
And then the memory of
being sexually abused
went in my mind, and I thought to myself,
"Why have I never shared
this with anyone in 25 years?
"Why have I kept this in and
been afraid to talk about it?"
And for whatever reason,
the environment of the
moment, the workshop
and people opening up, I was like,
"If I don't share this now,
"I'll probably never share
this, it'll go to my grave."
So I just stood up in front of the room.
And I remember I couldn't look
up at anyone in their eyes.
I was so ashamed of
what I was about to say,
so I just looked down at the carpet
and I just walked
through the entire event.
You know, when I was five years old,
I was at the babysitter's,
the babysitter had a son, a late teenager,
and he took me into the
bathroom and he raped me.
And I just shared the
story for the first time.
And I remember sitting down,
the whole room's silent.
I think people were just in shock
to see a straight white male,
who's this jock-looking
athlete, big guy, strong guy.
You know, probably had a
little bit of ego showing,
showing up during that
time, share that story.
'Cause I never heard, personally,
I never heard of another story of a man
being sexually abused, whether
I was not allowing myself
to read it or see it, or
I didn't see stories on TV
or I didn't see people, especially
athletes opening up about
this publicly online.
I just never saw it.
I remember sitting down after
sharing this and for whatever
reason, right when I sat down,
I just started erupting
with tears and emotion.
And there was two women
on each side of me,
who they're crying, they're hugging me.
I'm ashamed, I'm embarrassed.
I run out of the room.
I run out of the room,
out of the building in
this conference room
and I go outside and I'm like,
"I'm not going back in there.
"There's no way I could go
look at these people again.
"Now that they know the worst part of me,
"the thing I'm most ashamed of,
"the thing I'm most embarrassed of,
"the thing I feel the weakest about,
"how would anyone ever actually accept me,
"like me or love me after this moment?"
And probably one of the most
memorable and beautiful moments
of my life was what happened next.
I felt a tap on my shoulder
a few minutes later,
I'm crying outside by myself,
hand up against the wall.
I'm like, "I don't want
anyone to look at me.
"I'm so embarrassed."
I feel a tap on my
shoulder and I turn around
and it's this big, big
guy, guy bigger than me,
older than me, probably
in his late fifties.
He looks me straight in the eyes,
puts his hand around my shoulder.
And he said, "You're my hero.
"This happened to me when I was 13.
"My wife doesn't know,
I've got three kids.
"No one knows.
"I've never had the
courage to do what you just
"did in this moment.
"And it's, I felt like a
prisoner my entire life,
"holding this in.
"I'm gonna go tell my wife, thank you."
One by one, the men from
the room all came out
and they all shared stories with me.
You know, a lot of the
men were sexually abused.
The men who weren't sexually
abused had something else.
Some other challenge
that they were faced with
that they were unwilling to share
because they were
embarrassed by or ashamed.
And that was a big wake up
call for me where I realized
man, men in general, don't
have really a safe place
to share their shame.
And it's what made me want
to go down a path of like
researching, like how many
men has this happened to?
And I found one in six
men are sexually abused.
It's one in four for women.
Obviously women face it a lot more.
But as I started to write
my next book about this,
called the "Mask of Masculinity,"
I said, "You know, men, a
lot of the men in the world
"are causing a lot of
the pain in the world."
This is where you see some
of our leaders angry a lot.
And, and in my mind, some of them,
they're not looking for solutions to heal.
They're looking to create
more harm, more war,
more fighting, more anger.
And I said, "If men
started to heal their past,
"they would be much more loving
"and find better solutions in my opinion."
And I remember going on tour about my book
and I would get about 50/50 of the room,
men and women show up.
And I'd say, "Hey, just
show hands for the women.
"How many of you women in the room
"talk about your feelings?
"You know, once a once
a week with girlfriends,
"you talk about your marriage issues,
"your body image issues,
"your career, or whatever's
happening with your family.
"You talk about your stuff."
All the women raised their
hand once a week, right?
And I go, "Leave your hand up, women,
"if you do this every day.
"You're on the phone with a
girlfriend, you're at lunch,
"you're having tea, whatever it is."
And they're like, "Yep, this is every day
"we talk about our stuff."
And I go for the men in the room,
couple hundred men in the room.
I say, "Put your hand up
if you talk once a month
"with one man about your marriage issues,
"your body image issues,
your career stuff,
"your insecurities, your
fears, your doubts."
Maybe a couple of hands go up.
And I go, "Are you guys
part of a church group
"that does this once a month with 30 men
"to talk about this in a safe space?"
And they're like, "Yeah."
Pretty much everywhere I
went around the country.
And I said, "Women who had your hands up,
"imagine a world where you
never shared any of this ever,
"where you kept it in a deep
place inside of your heart
"and your soul, and you
never talked to a girlfriend
"about this, you never
felt you could share
"anything because you'd be shamed,
"you'd be made fun of,
you'd be called names,
"you'd be picked on, you'd
be punched in the face
"maybe if you shared some of
these things, just imagine."
Now I'm not saying it's
right what men have done
or what they do in bad situations.
I'm not saying any of
these things are justified,
but just imagine the pain and
suffering that some men feel
if they feel like they can
never share certain shames.
And I want to create a world
where men can find a safe
confidant or something where
they can share more frequently
their pain, because I feel like that pain
is causing pain in the world
when they don't share it.
So it's been an interesting journey.
- Well, it's so interesting
to hear you say that,
because I think we touched
on this a little bit
when I was on your show,
but one of the things that
people would say about Jordan
all the time, and especially
when we were on tour,
they would say it's all angry young men
who were showing up to his shows.
Now, first off, that just
wasn't true demographically.
It was usually about 60/40
to, you know, male to female,
but that's a pretty decent mix.
And it was black people and white people
and gay people and straight
people and all that.
But I always thought
the criticism was so odd
because even if it was a
hundred percent angry, white,
that was the other one,
they were white too,
which also wasn't true.
But let's say it was a hundred
percent angry, young white men.
Well, if his message was empowering them,
if his message was freeing them,
if his message was doing
actually everything that you just
described, well, then
that would be spectacular.
And yet it was framed as if, if you talk,
even if you talk to these
people, just by these people
showing up to a place together
that that somehow is evil,
which then just feeds the narrative
that they've already got in their heads.
- Yeah, I think for me,
I think I talked about
this briefly with you.
I don't know if it was
on our show or off camera
that I remember during my
first book I think it was,
I was on Ellen and then
I was on Glenn Beck
within a 24 hour window.
And I remember people being like,
how could you go on Glenn Beck?
I think Glenn Beck's a nice guy.
I like his stuff.
But if you're one way and you're,
you're not thinking that way,
then there might be controversy.
And I remember saying to myself, like,
just like Jordan Peterson,
his book's incredible.
You know, he has great principles.
I love his book and I'm
trying to just help humanity.
I don't care what you believe,
what you think is right and wrong.
I'm trying to lift people up
and give them tools to empower
themselves, to live in peace,
to live in power and to
inspire people around them.
And I think that's our mission.
- So I don't want to do
straight up politics with you.
I did not get an essay book of the things
that you won't talk about,
but I don't want to do politics with you,
because I think it's a good escape.
This is, this is meta politics in a way.
But in a time like we live in right now
where politics seems crazy,
everyone's trying to destroy each other,
all of those things.
Do you have any tricks that
you use for yourself or that
you've recommended to
other people to scale back?
I mean, one of the things
I try to show people
is that your worldview
just can't be political.
You know, if your
worldview is just politics,
you're always doing this,
you've got blinders on
and you need a much bigger
philosophical, religious, whatever it is,
whatever your world view is,
it needs to be much wider.
Do you have any tricks?
Because it seems like everyone everywhere.
And I know I'm sort of self
selected into this thing,
because when anyone sees me at the store,
they want to talk politics with me.
But, but I do sense it's
making people crazier.
- Crazy, man.
- It's making
people angrier.
You know, they just
released this big study
about how depressed
people are right now and.
- I remember when I started
being an entrepreneur
after leaving my brother's,
I paid 250 a month for my brother's place
to have a room from his place, right?
And I started making enough
money to get an apartment
for 495 a month.
And it was the scariest thing
to write a check for 495.
'Cause I was like, I
don't know how I'm gonna
pay this next month.
But I got the cheapest apartment
I could in Columbus, Ohio.
And I remember, and I didn't
have a car at the time.
So I was walking everywhere.
And I remember saying to myself,
"I'm not gonna get a TV."
And for the first few
years I didn't have a TV.
And I just focused on my
mission and my vision,
which was creation, which
was getting customers
and sales and adding value to
those customers and clients.
And not having a TV was a big blessing.
I love movies and I love TV.
So I would go to the movies all the time,
but I wouldn't allow myself to browse
and see chaos on a screen until midnight
and then go to sleep with
nightmares from the chaos.
So personally, I tried to,
I remember I had Marianne
Williamson on my show and I told
her, you know, "I really
don't watch the news."
And she goes, "That's, you
need to watch the news.
"Like you need to be informed,
"especially as like a white male,
"you need to know what's
happening in the world."
But you can get the news
from different places.
I don't need to watch
the TV to get the news.
I can check, you know,
Apple news or whatever,
or get someone to tweet me
something and check it out.
And people are gonna tell
you the news, no matter what.
- Right?
You can't really escape the news.
- I try to focus on, I truly
believe that when I focus
on giving to people and service,
I'm a happier human being.
And research has backed
science of happiness.
That when you're in
contribution to someone else,
whether it's opening the
door, buying a coffee,
having a conversation,
listening to someone
when they're going through something,
doing charity work, whatever it may be,
that makes you the happiest.
When we're giving to others.
So when we're focused on self,
and what we don't have,
suffering is the result of
obsessive, self-centric thinking.
So when I'm thinking of the news,
this is not working in my favor.
I need to, this is an outrage,
or I'm not happy about this,
'cause it's not helping me.
You're gonna be unhappy.
And I'm not saying you shouldn't
fight for what you want
and have things to change.
Sure.
But if you're gonna be,
if you want to be happier,
focus on other people, focus on service.
And also don't watch the news.
And as media companies, ourselves,
we want people to watch us.
But I think watch, focus on
things that bring you joy.
I think as adults, we don't play enough.
You know, in my studio, I got a Frisbee
and we love to work hard.
You know, our team works hard,
but I'll grab Matt, our
COO, my friend, and I say,
"We need five minutes just
to throw the Frisbee."
We need to play.
Who plays anymore?
- I know.
- Especially if you can't go
outside, you can't do this.
Who's playing?
- Well, I'm chasing a one year old dog.
- Exactly, right?
But I'm like a big advocate
of play over watching TV.
Go do something fun.
I went out to, was it, I've
been in LA for eight years.
How long have you been here?
- About eight years.
- Eight years.
- Yeah, Seven and a half.
- Literally, two days ago,
The first time I went to
Franklin Canyon Lake or park,
have you been to this place?
- I don't even know what that is.
- This is 10 minutes from here.
It's a lake and nature of like
a hundred acres in the middle
of LA and you can't see the city.
It's literally in the
middle of Mullholland Drive.
- Never heard of this place.
- It's unbelievable.
I saw a photo of it on Instagram.
- We got a lake?
- We got a lake and it's like ducks
and turtles and everything.
And I went there on Sunday
with my girlfriend and our dog.
And it was just like, we're in nature.
We're hanging out.
I'm not watching TV.
I'm not on social media.
I'm a big salsa dancer.
I love salsa.
- Really?
- For 15 years I've been salsa
dancing around the world.
I play guitar.
I like to play sports, workout.
I'm just like, go do something
that's gonna contribute
and benefit your life and
contribute and benefit
someone else's life.
When you do those things,
you're gonna be a better person.
I'm learning Spanish.
I'm trying all these different
things that get me away
from the train wreck of the news.
So that's what I recommend.
Don't obsess yourself into
what's not working for you.
Go be the change.
- Do you sense that right
now because of corona,
because of protests, because
everything is so seemingly
chaotic, that people are
becoming more receptive
to the type of stuff you're talking about,
because I can just, for me,
like I started gardening
since we started doing this.
I'll show you when we get out here,
we got a ton of, we're growing a ton
of great stuff out there.
- Grow some carrots, man.
- I got, real carrots, I got tomatoes,
I got cucumbers, I got zucchini.
I got broccoli, peppers.
But like I started doing that.
I'm cooking a lot more.
David usually cooks a ton,
but now I'm barbecuing all the time.
And like I'm refining some skills.
And like, I think there's
a unique opportunity
in this mess to either come out of it,
more skilled, more refined,
more passionate about what you do,
or maybe realize that
what you were doing before
isn't what you want to
do or all that stuff.
Versus some people that I think
are just gonna have slogged
through it and not really thought
about their life critically enough.
And then they'll just be on the other side
and the world'll be different.
- I'm on both sides here.
If you need to take a pause
and rest for these last three
months, because you've
been, go, go, go, go,
nonstop for 10 years, and
you had never taken a pause
in your life, this is
the most beautiful time
for you to sit around and do nothing
and read a book and lounge and not hustle.
So for some people, I think
that is what you need.
And personally, my
philosophy is I feel like
this is what the world needed in general,
is for us to take a pause
with technology being so fast,
with us on social media.
Most people are on
their phones six, seven,
eight hours a day.
And a lot of it's social media.
It's like, what are we
consuming our time with?
It's not what we're supposed
to be doing all day.
- Pretty sure it's not making us happier.
- It's not making us happier.
It's making us more neurotic of like,
I need more likes, I need more followers,
I need to, oh, what's
happening in the news?
It's just, it's craziness.
And so for some, I
think don't do anything.
And that's what you need.
You need to reevaluate why
your life isn't working,
why this relation, I'm
seeing so many people.
I'm not sure if you're seeing this,
a lot of big personalities are posting,
"We're getting a divorce.
"We're going through a breakup."
You're finally evaluating
your relationship.
- You're trapped in a house
with someone every minute
for three months and
you're constantly going,
"Do I like this guy?"
- You can't escape anymore.
So I think people are getting
clear on what they want.
'Cause they haven't been
clear for a long time,
maybe partly, but not fully.
So for some people you need a pause.
You need a break.
You need to evaluate, you
need to take inventory
of everything in your life
and create a new game plan moving forward.
You need to find some coaches and mentors
and have a game plan and go take action.
For other people, I'm
kind of in the middle.
I feel like I've hustled
more, my business,
I've hired more people.
I've been like more creative than ever,
but I'm also going to the park
and relaxing with my girlfriend
and my dog on the weekends,
which I would never do.
And I'm taking that time to be in nature.
So I feel like I'm trying to
do both and balance my personal
life, but then work going kind of all
in and getting clear on like,
what does our audience need right now?
What does our customers need?
What do they need for the
next five to 10 years,
if this doesn't change?
So I'm a little in the middle
and I have empathy for both
sides, but I think if you can rediscover
what you want to do in your
life and who you want to become,
whether you take action on it
now or just discover it now,
that's what we should be doing.
- How do you decide how much stuff
to put out there in the midst of all this?
'Cause a lot of what you're
talking about is to ease
up on this stuff.
Go live your life, get
out there in nature,
et cetera, et cetera.
I think I mentioned to you last
time, like people say to me,
Dave, why don't you do
an interview every day?
Do five interviews a week,
do seven interviews a
week and we do one or two.
And then I obviously do some other stuff.
And I, it's not for a lack of time,
but it really in many reasons
for a respect of my audience.
- Of people's time.
- Yeah, like it's,
'cause I, it's like if you listen to me,
then hopefully you listened
to one of your episodes.
Maybe you listened to Sam
Harris or Joe Rogan or whatever.
It's like, I want you to, that's great.
If you give a couple hours
of your week to this stuff,
that's fantastic, but I
don't want you to give
40 hours of your week.
So I don't even want you to give 20 hours
of your week to this.
So like, I think it's
important what we're doing,
it's valuable what we're doing,
but how do you decide like what's enough
and what's too much?
- Three factors.
One is like, what is my audience?
What I think my audience
wants and my intuitive side
of what I think they
are gonna want or need.
What works for me personally.
Like I don't want to be on every day
doing an interview either.
It's a lot of energy.
What personally works for
my life, my lifestyle,
my vision for the future.
And then what does the data say?
And I know you're
probably very data driven
as well with your team.
- You have to be.
- Gotta be if you're
in the media business.
So we're looking at how can
we create content on certain
platforms more and less
on other platforms,
based on the data?
So I'm kind of thinking
of those three things,
my personal energy and time,
intuitively what I
think my audience needs.
And what's the data saying?
And we're making decisions based on that.
- I think we did it all here.
Well, you know what?
I got one more for you.
I'm gonna loosely quote a
pretty decent interviewer.
What is greatness to you?
- Greatness to me, it has
changed over the years
and I think it will
always evolve and change
until we find kind of our
true purpose and mission.
For me currently in the moment,
it's discovering your unique
talents and gifts that you were
born with, developing those in the pursuit
of your dreams and in that pursuit,
making an impact on the people around you.
I think we do that, we
figure out who we are,
what our talents are and cultivate them.
We go pursue the thing
that brings us a lot of joy
and we make other people
happy and impacted around us,
in a positive way.
I feel like that's greatness.
- Plus we're in a great jacket, man.
- It's clean.
You have buyer's remorse now.
(laughing)
- It's @lewishowes on Twitter.
If you'd like to be inspired, motivated,
and educated by some of
the most successful people
around the world, check out
the School of Greatness,
full episode playlist right over here.
And if you'd like to see Lewis
Howes' interview with me,
click right over here and to get notified
of all future videos, be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell.